Danger. Other people. So so,
so my question then is when I was
physically threatened on Twitter,
you guys refuse to take down the tweet
and I showed up in Berkeley and someone
physically threatened me
because they were encouraged to,
when I was in Venezuela I was physically
threatened by high profile individual,
10,000 people tweeting at me.
You guys do nothing. Right?
So I guess there's the obvious question
of why does it always feel like your
policies are going one
direction politically?
You say it's about behavior and you said
several times already, but I've already,
I've got a ton of examples
of that not being the case
and you will always be
able to find those exams.
Yeah. Examples where you guys were
alerted multiple times and did nothing.
Like when Antifa docs,
a bunch of law enforcement agents,
some of the tweets are removed,
but since September this tweet is still
alive with a list of private phone
numbers addresses. Yet
Kathy Griffin, she's fine.
The guy who threatened the lives of
these kids in Covington and said,
lock him in school and burn it down. You
did nothing. I mean he got to spend it.
I take his tweets down. Was he banned
for threatening the lives of kids?
Absolutely not.
So again, we have an, um, I'm happy
to talk about all these details.
We have our policies that are meant to
protect people and are meant to enable
for expression as long as you're
not trying to silence somebody else.
Now we take a variety of different
enforcement mechanisms around that.
Sometimes you get warned, sometimes we
were, your tweet is forced to be deleted.
It's a very rare occasion where we will
outright suspend someone without any
sort of warning or any sort of, um,
ability to understand what happened.
What did you guys do with Kathy Griffin
when she was saying she wanted the names
of those young kids were in the mag
of hats at the Covington high school.
That's all right. That's a great example,
Joe. So in that particular case, you know,
our doxing policy really focuses
on, uh, posting private information,
which we don't consider names to be
private. We consider your home address,
your home phone, your home phone
number, or your mobile phone number,
those types of things to be private.
So in that particular case we took what
I think now is probably a very literal
interpretation of our policy. And so
that, that was not a doxing incident.
Do you think that was an error?
I think that it was shortsighted and
given the context of what was going on
there, that um, if I was
doing this all over again,
I would probably ask my team to look at
that through the lens of what was the
purpose behind that tweet.
And if the purpose was in fact to identify
these kids to either docs in them or
abusing, harassing him,
which it probably was,
then we should be taking
a more expansive view of,
of that policy and including
that type of content,
especially considering the
fact they're minors. I mean,
I would think that right away
that would be like the approach.
So this is a trial and error sort of
learn and grow and move on with new
information sort of.
Yeah,
absolutely. We're gonna learn,
we're gonna make a ton of mistakes.
We're trying to do this,
uh,
with hundreds of millions of accounts
all around the world, numerous languages.
We're going to make mistakes.
Even if we get better,
there will always be mistakes,
but we're hoping to learn from those and
to make ourselves better and to catch
cases like Tim's or others where
we clearly may have made an error.
And I'm open to having those discussions.
I'm not,
I'm sorry Tim familiar
with your specific cases,
but I'd love to follow up with you and
I just want to see the tweet we don't
need to pull up. So it's a, B I t. Dot.
L Y slash Antifa tweet,
all lower case.
This is also an evolution
in prioritization as well.
Wondering one of the things we've
come to recently is we do, we do need,
we do need to prioritize these efforts
both in terms of policy enforcement, um,
how we're thinking about evolving them.
Um,
one of the things that we want to focus
on as number one is physical safety.
And this leads you immediately
to something like doxing.
And right now the only way we take action
on a docksin case is if it's reported
or not. Where we want to move to is to
be able to recognize those in real time,
at least in the English language,
recognize those in real time through
our machine learning algorithms and take
the action before it has to report it.
So we're focused purely right now on
going after a Dachsund cases with our
algorithms so that we can be proactive.
That also requires a much more rigorous
appeals process to correct us when we're
wrong,
but we think it's tightly scoped enough.
It impacts the most important thing,
which is someone's physical safety.
Once we learned from that,
we can really look at the,
the biggest issue with our system right
now is all the burden is placed upon the
victim. So we only act based on reports.
We don't have a lot of enforcement.
Um, especially with,
with more of the more,
the more of the take downs that are
run through machine learning and deep
learning algorithm.
But if something is reported,
a human does review it eventually or
are there a series of reports that you
never get to?
There's, there's probably
reports we don't, I mean we,
we prioritize the queue
based on severity and the,
the thing that Walmart severity is
something like physical safety or private
information or whatnot.
So generally we try to get through
everything but we have to prioritize that
cute even coming in.
So if, if someone threatened the
lives of someone else, you would,
would you band that account?
Would you tell them like,
like let's say someone tweeted
three times, kill these people.
I want them dead three times.
Is that yes. Violin. You didn't,
you didn't ban him though. Let's pull
that up Jamie. That's a, I don't know.
I don't,
I don't necessarily want to give out
specific user names because then people
just point the finger at me and
saying I'm getting these people band.
But you know, during Covington
this guy said multiple times too.
He wanted his followers
to go and kill these kids.
Yeah.
And we have to look at that,
but we also have to look in the
context because we also have,
I think we talked about this a little
bit in the last podcast, but we,
we have gamers on the platform who are
saying exactly that to their friends that
they're going to meet at the
game in the game tonight.
And without the context of
their relationship with,
at the context of the
conversation that we're having,
we would take the exact same action on,
on them incorrectly.
Yeah, absolutely. That
I, that I understand.
I think in the case of Covington though,
this user was so high profile,
he's a verified user.
He's got something like 20,000 followers
and it was highlighted by numerous
conservative media outlets saying,
wow, this guys, it screenshot it.
It's being shared.
I mean you had a Disney producer in like
saying a picture of a woodchipper with
a body being thrown in saying that's
what he wanted to happen, you know?
So I do know that some of
these accounts got locked.
Disney producer was doing that. Well,
I'll, I'll clarify fact check me on that.
But that's the, basically the
conversation that was had it,
there's a guy at Disney was,
he posted a picture of him Fargo of
someone being tossed into woodchip are and
he says, I want all these Maga
kids, you know, done like this.
You had another guy who specifically said
lock them in the school, Barnett down,
set a bunch of disparaging things and
then said if you see them fire on that
many tweeted that more than once
and that those accounts where
those streets were taken down,
those were violations of our rules.
That's,
I'm pretty sure it's actually illegal
to do that. Right. It's to, to to tell,
to tell you or any individual to
commit a felony is a crime like right.
Incitement of violence or yeah.
Yeah. So I have in many places,
I just have to wonder how, how,
like I understand the context issue,
but this is what,
this is what I talk.
What were those context and
scale too though, right? The Tim,
those accounts were actioned.
They may not have been action the
way you wanted to too, but the,
the tweets were forced to be deleted.
And the account I can penalty for that.
So I understand that.
But kind of a penalty. Well, again,
as I said earlier, Joe, we don't, uh,
usually uh,
automatically suspend accounts with
one violation because we want people to
learn,
we want people to understand what they
did wrong and give them an opportunity
not to do it again.
Right?
And it's a big thing to kick someone
off the platform and I take that very,
very seriously.
So,
so I want to make sure that
when someone violates our rules,
they understand what happened and they're
given an opportunity to, you know,
get back on the platform
and change their behavior.
And so in many of these cases,
what happens is we will force someone
to acknowledge that their tweet violated
our rules,
forced them to delete that tweet before
they can get back on the platform.
And in, in many cases, if they do
it again, we give them a timeout,
which is like seven days. When we
say, look, you've done it again,
the temporary suspension. If you do it
again, you're a mom and the totally a mom.
Exactly. And your mom too. And if you
do it again, then you're done. Right?
So it's kind of like, you know, three
strikes. So it's Sorta like baseball.
And so in some of these
cases at Tim's referencing,
I have to imagine because
these tweets were deleted,
they are violations of our rules.
People are upset that the account came
back again and was allowed to say other
things. But we did take action on those
streets. They were violations of our.